what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back with dark crisis on infinite
Earths now in the last video that we did
basically Hal Jordan the Green Lantern
had been captured by Pariah and thrown
into what's basically a pocket reality a
false reality and the result of this is
that Hal Jordan doesn't initially
succumb to it and in fact he largely
just kind of ignores it now we didn't
know exactly how all this was gonna
unfold all we knew was that it was
sector Jon Stewart but one of the things
that kind of gives us a clue here is
that Hal Jordan is referred to as
Parallax now this all kind of goes back
to the events of emerald Twilight and
actually sort of Builds on it so for
those of you guys who aren't familiar
with that story Emerald Twilight was an
unofficial tie-in to the death of
Superman in the sense that after
Superman had died a villain by the name
of Cyborg Superman who was one of the
replacement Supermen in a weird story
had basically shown up and alongside
another villain and then destroyed the
home city of Hal Jordan when Hal Jordan
got back he basically recreated the
entire city using his Green Lantern ring
which basically was against the rules he
was chastised by the guardian he was
kicked out of the Green Lantern Corps he
ended up basically using his ring to
kill pretty much all the Green Lanterns
and the Guardians of the universe and
started calling himself Parallax now I
know there are people who are going to
respond and be like
fear entity so here's the thing about
this Jeff Johns came back later on and
what he said is how Jordan was not
actually calling himself Parallax he was
but he wasn't instead what had happened
is that Parallax who's basically the
fear entity right the representative of
the yellow lanterns if you want to call
it that had basically been held prisoner
in the Green Lantern central power
battery so Hal Jordan had slowly been
infected by Parallax so during the
original Emerald Twilight story when he
was calling himself Parallax it's
because he was quite literally possessed
right so that's what Jeff Johns did in
terms of his greatly huge retcon but the
important thing here is that's why
they're referring to him as Parallax is
because it's a part of how Jordan's
really Green Lantern in history that
whether you're talking about the
original version or the Jeff John's
retcon is still a very important part of
the character's history and so what
seems to have happened at least in this
alter internet Universe we'll learn more
about these alternate realities as we go
on that seemingly in this alternate
universe Hal Jordan did go crazy he did
become Parallax maybe Jon Stewart you
know ended up Surviving Kyle Rayner was
made in new Green Lantern and all this
stuff exists as it does now the reality
is we don't really see much of it
instead basically Barry Allen comes
flying out of nowhere and rescues Hal
Jordan now Barry Allen was taken or was
saved from his alternate reality prison
that happened technically the comic says
that it happened in the flash issue 783
through 785 it's really more like 784
and 785 783 is basically the other
speedsters going into the Multiverse 784
is when basically Wally West meets Barry
Allen and then 785 is when Barry Allen
is saved by Wally the way this worked is
that when Wally West showed up and Barry
Allen's alternate reality prison very
thought he was eobard Thon and basically
he thought he was reverse flash alright
so the two of them started fighting now
eventually Wally woke him up to the fact
that it is actually Wally kind of a
reverse from what we saw from DC rebirth
when Wally West returned for the first
time Barry remembered him therefore
Wally could be pulled out of the speed
force where basically Barry remembers
Wally again and so Wally can save Barry
from his alternate reality prison all of
his memories and everything started
flooding back I didn't really cover it
because in all honesty The Flash tie-in
is just an enormous missed opportunity
literally nothing meaningful happens in
that story except that Wally basically
fights Barry for a little bit and like
that's it which is kind of a clickbait
title right Wally West versus Barry
Allen Flash versus Flash whatever but
nonetheless it's one of those cool
things because with Barry being here and
basically rescuing how how hadn't really
succumbed to the reality yet so his
memories hadn't really been wiped clean
or anything along those lines so
basically it's the two of them just kind
of trying to find a way out but more so
than that trying to find the different
members of the Justice League which is
really Paramount now the next thing we
do is switch over to Black Adam where
Black Adam is basically meeting with the
Legion of Doom right Lex Luthor's
villainous group and initially the
Legion of Doom kind of rejects him but
Black Adam literally says okay here's
one of the things it's not the first
time that we as the villains came
together in the absence of the
superheroes again referencing the events
of forever evil when a justice league
from an alternate reality invaded the
main DC Universe and the superheroes
were defeated so the villains had to
pick up the slack but initially they're
all just kind of against it because the
reality is if Deathstroke is running
around killing all the superheroes why
would they stop it right like he's
literally doing the job for them but the
responsive Black Adam is it's much
bigger than Deathstroke just
annihilating superheroes he's bringing
the great Darkness I mean if it was one
of those things where Deathstroke was
just like you know what all the
superheroes got to die I'm gonna go
ahead and take them all out of my own
you'd get no argument from me there but
in this circumstance what Black Adam
says is like what Deathstroke is doing
is literally leading to the death of all
creation which includes you and me so we
need to band together and find a way to
defeat this guy but before any of that
happens Deathstroke makes his move
against the Legion of Doom which he saw
coming when he saw this whole situation
happening here and so what you end up
getting is Barry and Hal Jordan who
basically raced through the Multiverse
and into the prison of Batman into his
reality now the funny thing about this
is that Bruce Wayne as he's here is is a
much darker version of himself than were
traditionally used to and in fact it is
kind of interesting to a degree because
in a lot of ways Joshua Williamson sort
of walks the line that in truth here
we're kind of given this perspective
that Bruce Wayne much like Barry Allen
is trapped in this pocket reality right
like literally his imagination creates
it and so he's essentially stuck here
because everything that he believes is
happening is real but the other part of
this is that Batman is the world's
greatest detective so Joshua Williamson
kind of toes that line and kind of
giving us a situation not really in so
many words where it's like Batman does
kind of know what's going on but he
likes where he is and so it's almost
like he doesn't necessarily want to
leave now of course Very and Batman had
met before but Batman had overcome Barry
and Barry was forced to flee and that's
why he's grabbed Hal Jordan and that's
why he's brought him back here and so it
is kind of a cool moment because you do
have a few things that come together at
the same time the first thing is that
you basically have Alan Scott in the
Justice Society of America that grab
Jonathan Kent the son of Superman along
with what's basically the Titans and
bring them to the headquarters of
justice league dark now justice league
dark of course is basically the
supernatural version of the Justice
League so that's where you have like
John Constantine and all those different
characters right Swamp Thing and so on
and so forth but again one of the things
that we had covered in the deadly green
tie-in is that Swamp Thing Jonathan Ken
and those guys had traveled to meet the
great darkness and what they found is
the great Darkness doesn't really have
any aspirations to destroy everything it
has no desire to conquer all of
existence it simply just is the absence
of everything in existence but it simply
just exists like that's literally it
right it's just a thing that's there and
so what they realize is the great
Darkness isn't actually doing all of
this instead it's Pariah who's basically
been corrupted or at least has corrupted
the great darkness and is using the
great darkness's power so if we want to
use an example here Pariah is a drop of
ink falling into water right literally
it changes the color of the water it's
tainted the great Darkness now it is a
pretty Monumental feat right for those
of you guys coming from Marvel Comics it
would be like somebody corrupting the
the one above all right something like
it's it's all it it's evil Alter Ego if
you want to call it that but basically
just a being of insurmountable power
that normally doesn't care about Good
and Evil but now wants to destroy
everything because it's kind of been
corrupted and twisted and made to
believe that that's the way the things
you're supposed to be so with the Legion
of Doom of course you kind of get a few
things that happen here pretty fast for
the most part the Legion of Doom being
led by Deathstroke is now corrupted by
the great Darkness itself and so
Deathstroke secret six right is
basically kind of dark villainous team
have all been corrupted by the great
Darkness now while they don't have like
an astronomical amount of power it is
enough to amp them up beyond their
normal levels so when you have the
Legion of Doom facing off against the
forces of Deathstroke they're for the
most part being overtaken quite readily
right like literally under any normal
circumstance most of these guys would
get crushed by the Legion of Doom
because a Legion of Doom is kind of like
the anti-justice league team right it
has been for decades ever since its
invention in DC Comics but it's also
composed of some of the strongest
villains that exist in DC Comics
Sinestro Lex Luthor with all of his
intelligence so on and so forth right
these are highly capable people and so
to have someone who's just small beans
right small fries taking out or at least
holding their own against the Legion of
Doom it's pretty impressive it's a huge
deal and that's when the legion starts
to realize that ultimately Deathstroke
is the one that's behind all this right
Deathstroke's literally the guy who's
leading the secret six now Lex Luthor's
the first one to figure that out of
course again just because of the fact
that he's so intelligent but he also
overestimates his his capabilities right
the dunning-kruger effect overestimating
what he's capable of and when he goes to
attack Deathstroke he initially gets the
upper hand but what ends up happening is
one of the forces of Deathstroke come
out of nowhere and infect Lex Luthor and
the reason why is because Lex didn't
really seem to be giving a lot of
attention to the fact that the more
individuals that are defeated by the
forces of Deathstroke those individuals
are in turn corrupted by the great
darkness and literally the numbers
bolster so what's really going on here
is Deathstroke secret six is expanding
at a geometric rate for every one person
they infect that person infects too they
in turn effect two of their own and so
on and so forth it just goes
exponentially right it's just at an
astronomical level so Things Fall pretty
fast and so once the great Darkness
takes over seemingly everybody all this
energy again is being fed directly to
Pariah which again he's basically using
for his own goal and what ends up
happening here is Pariah basically uses
all of this power to recreate the
Multiverse now here's something that I
want to establish here because this is
something that really seemed to confuse
a lot of people when I was looking at
the comments of my video and looking on
Reddit and social media and different
things like that so the way this works
in DC Comics is as we talked about
before you basically had death metal
rights like the Batman who laughs and
you had perpetua and the Multiverse and
all that kind of stuff but one of the
things to understand is that after DC
rebirth it wasn't creating a new
Multiverse it was taking the existing
Multiverse and saying all that history
is still there and so the Multiverse as
it existed from Infinite Crisis when it
was basically brought back after the
events of crisis on infinite Earth so
Multiverse 2 if you want to call that
from that Multiverse up until literally
this moment right now it's been the same
Multiverse but it's just changing what
what the history of that Multiverse is
what Pariah is doing is recreating the
original Multiverse that existed before
the events of crisis on infinite Earth
that's literally what he's done now the
kicker to all this is that even when
this Multiverse is restored the biggest
problem here is that it's unstable right
like literally it's an unstable process
the different worlds basically start
cracking they start working apart
because there's not enough energy here
to keep them together right it's like
you trying to bench press a thousand
pounds right like your body will just
collapse and that's basically what's
happening here and so what you end up
doing is switching over to Hal Jordan
and Barry Allen as they face off against
Batman now one of the cool things here
is that as they're fighting and as
they're literally going at it what Hal
does is he actually ties into Bruce
Wayne now this is actually a genius
maneuver by Joshua Williamson because
he's building not only on really what
like Scott Snyder did in the new 52 the
different writers of Batman beforehand
but also when what Tom King did because
one of the things that have happened
over the years and we could really kind
of go back to Grant Morrison if we
really want to Grant Morrison's Batman
run is that the significance of the bat
family has always been a very important
part of Bruce Wayne's life it goes back
to Dick Grayson then you had Jason Todd
and then you had Tim Drake you had
Stephanie Brown you had all these
different robins and different Sidekicks
that have come into Batman's life but
they've always been an important part of
his family one of the beautiful things
that Tom King did which I don't think a
lot of people were able to appreciate is
he focused more on the interpersonal
relationship between Bruce Wayne and
basically everybody around him as
opposed to Batman fighting the Joker
again you know yay and like that kind of
that kind of Simplicity and basic
storytelling and so focusing on that
Williamson ties into this idea that
while Batman doesn't necessarily show it
on an emotional level his family means
everything to him and so when Hal Jordan
literally uses his uh his ring to create
constructs of the bat family that he
shows to Bruce Wayne and it's like this
is your family man not this this place
that you're in right now this is not
home it's not your home what it does is
it snaps Bruce Wayne back and when it
does he basically is essentially freed
from his prison but the question they
have here is where do we go next right
like what do we do now and so ultimately
what ends up happening is Batman says
okay if what we're looking to do is
basically wake up the other members of
the Justice League then we have to find
the one person that represents truth
above all else who else do you know who
is an expert in truth who basically
never Falls prey to things like this and
so before we end up finding out what
that is we basically jump back to what
is in effect the Hall of Justice right
the former headquarters of the Justice
League before they were all whisked away
to these alternate reality prisons and
held by by Pariah now initially you have
basically Dick Grayson that brings
everybody together and there is a little
bit of concern or question as to whether
or not Dick Grayson Can Be an Effective
leader but one of the things that we've
talked about in previous videos is the
Justice Society of America is the
precursor to the Justice League of
America so while the JSA is powerful I
would argue they're not really as
powerful from top to bottom as the
Justice League however their word is
highly respected right everyone stops
and listens when the Justice Society of
America stands up and talks that's the
level of respect they have for them not
only that you basically have Alan Scott
the Green Lantern sure he's not the most
powerful of the Green Lanterns but again
it's more about the position he holds
than it is the power he possesses and he
actually makes this compelling Point
here and what he says is Dick Grayson
should be the one to lead this group and
the reason why is because Dick Grayson
is one the best of us and two he's the
first person to really lead out from
under the shadow of a main superhero and
Forge his own path now in some ways this
is Williamson kind of hitting it like
the actual income and book history of
Dick Grayson but this is really more him
talking about the significance of Dick
Grayson from a publishing perspective in
DC Comics that is the importance of Dick
Grayson the importance of his character
is the fact that he's the one that left
the purview of Batman he's the one that
walked away from being a sidekick and
became his own superhero the first real
time that happened in DC Comics for a
major player in their lineup and ever
since then Dick Grayson has just been a
major focal point of DC he's never
really lost popularity he's never really
been a character that people don't care
about they don't necessarily like all
the stories that were written about him
but there's a big difference between not
liking a character's story and not
caring about a character at all if you
didn't care about him you wouldn't even
read their story so you wouldn't have
any reason to complain so it's one of
those things that's that's really
interesting when it comes to how Dick
Grayson works but at the same moment
when all this happens you basically have
justice league dark this shows up again
Jonathan Kent coming off the heels of
everything that we covered with regards
to uh the deadly green which again is
why we kind of did it when we did but
Jonathan basically comes out and gives
this Revelation to the rest of the of
the Justice League or the Titans that
like this is not one of those things
where like you know the great darkness
wants to destroy everything it's a
source of power being used by Pariah for
his own ends now this simplifies things
immensely because what it means is that
if they can find a way to destroy Pariah
the great Darkness won't seemingly want
to conquer anything anymore right it'll
literally just kind of leave because the
corruptive agent inside of its its
Essence has been destroyed right it's
like destroying a flu or a cold your
body's immune system just kind of goes
back to normal instead of being in
hyperdrive facing off against this
foreign body and so what what Dick
Grayson also basically establishes here
is the reason why they want to bring
everybody together is because first and
foremost they have to find a way to
defeat Deathstroke when he first popped
up on the scene he was just a guy taking
pot shots at various superheroes in the
absence of the Justice League now he's
formed in a mint Army that's like a few
hundred strong and so the response of
them of of of Dick Grayson is let's get
them all here and let's get all the
superheroes here we'll deal with
Deathstroke we'll take him out and then
when that's done we'll focus on
everybody else and so it really is an
amazing moment because you literally
have the Titans that just go lunging
into battle against the forces of
Deathstroke It Is by all standards a
measurement even if it's only
earth-based a pretty significant crisis
type event under previous instances in
DC Comics whether you're looking at
crisis is on infinitas or Infinite
Crisis or final crisis to a degree those
events are confined to Earth that's
where most of DC stuff takes place but
it had a much bigger feeling in terms of
different people around the universe all
facing off against their own threats in
some capacity as part of the larger
crisis event which is why this story is
really more toned down in comparison to
a lot of the past crises that DC's done
but what we end up doing is that while
this fight basically breaks out we
switch over to Kent farm right like the
the reality where Superman's currently
being held prisoner and the funny thing
about this is that kind of off panel
Batman and Hal Jordan and Barry Allen
had basically freed uh Diana right they
freed Wonder Woman when they get here
what they find out is that Clark Kent
has not succumbed to this reality he
knows it's not real he knows that
nothing he sees here is real moreover
Superman has received a massive power
boost because what he reveals here is
that he tried to escape this place so
many times but he couldn't get out of it
right like literally it's a prison
created by a guy whose power dwarfs the
power of Superman so he simply just
couldn't escape so what he said is like
if I can't leave then what I'll do
instead is I'll study and I will learn
and I'll learn everything about this
universe that I possibly can so what
Superman had been doing this entire time
is basically absorbing all the cosmic
energy within this pocket reality
basically it's Superman who's been amped
up to Cosmic levels this guy possesses
the power of a universe and it's crazy
because there's gonna come a point in
this story where Superman appears
basically in like this perfect moment
and he never would have been able to
pull it off had it not been for the
massive power boost that he has but it's
literally him running around with an
astronomical amount of power now back to
what's going on with Pariah with him
doing his whole situation one of the
things to keep in mind is that Hal
Jordan entering into or being captured
by Pariah was the result of the fact
that Pariah had basically what was left
of the Green Lantern Corps facing off
against his forces and that fight's
still happening right like literally
right over there like a hundred feet
away from Pariah you've got like Kyle
Raynor and you have all these different
Green Lanterns that are facing off
against these forces and he's just kind
of conjured using the great Darkness
Each of which is a challenge for the
Green Lanterns But as time progresses
Pariah starts to realize how unstable
the Multiverse is he starts to realize
how unstable and corrupt all of this is
and so one of the things to know at
least as it's being done right now is
Joshua Williamson kind of establishes
you have two multiverses coexisting at
the same time following the events of
the original crisis on infinite Earth
again the Multiverse was destroyed
during Infinite Crisis it was brought
back and while DC has kind of alluded to
this idea that there are an infinite
number of universes but we there's only
52 that we know of what Williamson is
doing here is basically saying there are
only 52 universes in the Multiverse but
Pariah bringing back the original
Multiverse basically brings the string
of infinite universes that join the
existing Multiverse right so if infinity
plus 52 that's basically what you're
looking at here but again all this inner
energy and all this power this
Multiverse is basically unstable because
there's not enough power from the
superheroes that have been captured to
keep it floating not only that because
Barry Allen Hal Jordan Batman Diana
right Wonder Woman uh Superman because
they've escaped their confinements the
source of power that was being used by
Pariah is now gone it's like basically
kicking the ladder out from under a
person just comes crashing down to the
ground and that's really what's going on
here right but the other thing about
this is the power that's being emitted
by Deathstroke and the different
superheroes that have basically been
corrupted by the great Darkness that's
also feeding this Multiverse and that's
the reason why it hasn't completely and
totally just shattered exploded and led
to the ruin of everything because it
still does have a source of power just
not as much as it had before but in the
midst of this whole Discovery Pariah is
suddenly met by the arrival of the
Justice League literally they pop up
here on the scene Cosmic Superman
leading the charge and I just gotta say
guys this version of Superman looks dope
like it's amazing how awesome this guy
looks and I got be honest man like it's
just it's it's one of the best looks for
his character that I think I've ever
seen that's one of the coolest things
man DC doesn't always nail it when they
write Superman's stories but damn it if
they don't know how to make a badass
costume for that guy he just he gets the
greatest looks I think out of all the
different superheroes that exist out
there but one of the things that that
Pariah basically reveals is look here's
the thing the energy that I needed from
you guys when we were when you were in
your prison was basically enough energy
to essentially create this new
Multiverse in the play in the first
place sure you're free of your prisons
but now for the Multiverse is here
Deathstroke has his whole campaign and
for every single superhero and super
villain that he defeats on Earth they
become a part of the Great darkness and
their energy feeds this Multiverse so
literally I'm in no shortage of power
all I have to do is find some way to
stabilize this new Multiverse that I've
made and the end is not all of you will
basically cease to exist I will destroy
and eradicate every single one of you
and that'll be the end of the day right
that'll be the end of the game and
that's when they come to this
realization there basically is no way to
stop all of this there's seemingly no
way to end any of this it doesn't appear
to be the case not only that to make
things more complicated here where you
have the Justice League and you have all
these different guys who are on the
scene and you've even got that fight
going on on Earth there's two things to
understand here the first is that Pariah
is enough to take on these members of
the Justice League he defeated them
before there's no reason to believe he
can't defeat them again especially
because now he has the the entire power
of this new Multiverse at his disposal
which amps his abilities even further
but on Earth he basically unleashes the
entirety of his Dark Army on everyone so
now you have Deathstroke who's basically
leading an army with Pariah at the head
along with doomsday dark side necron the
head of the of the Black Lanterns I mean
the list goes on and on and to make
things even worse the Specter right the
living embodiment of basically God's
vengeance is here it's effectively the
end times man I can't really see a way
where they're able to pull off off the
victory here but with that being said
guys we're going to bring this video to
an end thank you all for watching and I
will catch you all later peace